thank you
finally finally the attention I deserve
happy Wednesday everyone so mental
illness really is a problem in this
country of course history shows that the
mentally ill have always been with us
but
now our mostly Democrat run cities are a
wash in serious mental cases roaming the
streets it's sad several decades ago
this country decided that
institutionalizing our mentally ill was
somehow a violation of their rights it's
a pretty unique take on the Constitution
that it's every citizen's right to eat
from garbage cans and treat our
sidewalks like toilets I don't remember
James Madison actually adding that what
we should have realized by now is that
allowing those who can't care for
themselves to attempt to care for
themselves isn't respecting their rights
it's condemning them to hunger disease
and a lonely death on a frozen sidewalk
much like the future of any CNN
anchor but any caring Society should do
what it can to help those who can't
can't help themselves now to be clear
when I say mentally ill I'm talking
about those who are truly broken the
ones who live on the streets in an
alternate reality who scream at demons
who aren't there and who hear voices and
who all too often listen to the voices
that tell them to hurt someone those
voices never tell raving psychos to do
anything positive like say
retire so considering how much damage to
themselves and Society the mental eel do
why is it more being done to actually
help well as the old saying goes follow
the money today in our city and state
governments the homeless industrial
complex has become a Power Silo just
like any other in NYC every day feels
more menacing and predictable than Dana
Pino before her midday nap and yet the
department of homeless Services employs
2,000 people and has an annual budget
that has grown to over $2 billion and
take a guess who controls all those jobs
all that money it's almost always Dems
apparently insanity is voting for the
same party over and over and expecting
different results so every time a
disturbed homeless guy pushes a woman in
front of a subway car homeless service
Executives they don't hear the screams
they hear cash registers the homicidal
Maniacs are putting their kids through
college more empathy they demand more
Personnel more cars more pensions but
somehow never more tough love never
anything that actually works because
then the problem would be solved and a
solved problem means no more money it's
a swamp of a different sort one that
we're all stuck in especially if you
live in a Dem run crappy city so it
sounds like we need someone to drain
that swamp and who might
[Music]
[Applause]
volunteer you know I wonder when he's
back in the white house will he use
every tool lever and authority to get
the homeless off our
streets when I'm back in the white house
we will use every tool lever and
authority to get the homeless off our
streets and for those who are severely
mentally ill and deeply disturb we will
bring them back to mental institutions
where they belong with the goal of
reintegrating them back into society
once they are well enough to
manage sort of seems like Common Sense
doesn't it and do you want proof of that
well the ACLU opposes it now there's
nothing a progressive likes more than a
new grievance group adding mentally ill
homeless to the roster of the oppressed
is yet another big kaching for them soon
they'll Hear Voices telling them to vote
for Joe Biden but there's a limit to how
much money even Washington can churn out
the printing presses are starting to
melt down and so finally even some demp
cities are feeling the heat in Boston
the Democrat mayor signed legislation
that takes effect today allowing cops to
dismantle a homeless encampment known as
the methadone mile trust me no matter
what the 20 the Century 21 agent tells
you don't buy in a neighborhood with
that
name also starting this month police in
Portland will be able to enforce a ban
on what officials there are calling
daytime camping daytime
camping it's the perfect liberal
euphemism you know like shooting heroin
between your toes is something you
learned in the Boy
Scouts and after residents and store
owners in Phoenix brought a lawsuit a
federal judges forcing that City to
clean out a downtown homeless camp known
as The Zone so what's going on here well
maybe some Democrats know they're in
trouble and are going a bit trumpy as we
approach an election year but as someone
once great someone great once said never
confuse movement with action I think it
was my
gastroenterologist because as these
officials move the homeless around none
of them will use Trump's key phrase we
will bring the severely Disturbed two
mental institutions that's right it's
that thing every parlor Revolution
tionary dreads Force which is necessary
or it won't work crazy people rarely
agree that they're crazy now studies
throughout history have shown that
humans find green surroundings in a
quiet Countryside soothing but what
could be better for the mental ill for
whom every honking horn can be a torture
forcibly bringing the truly Disturbed to
Countryside facilities where they can be
given to Hots in a cot and treated
humanely and with even the possibility
of release at some point that's not on
their rights it's salvaging their most
basic right to live with dignity and not
die alone and degradation among
maddening crowds and Diesel beling buses
and it'll ultimately be cheaper than the
endless catch and release programs that
we have now but like so many other good
ideas it has two key fatal flaws it
makes perfect sense and there's no money
in it because if they fixed homelessness
those bureaucrats would be the ones out
in the
street let's welcome tonight's guests
make fun of her glasses and she'll kick
all of your asses poost of Kennedy Saves
the World podcast
Kennedy finally someone named Hunter who
didn't bang his brother's widow comedian
Adam
Hunter her last name is only one of 648
words that end
in New York Times bestselling author in
Fox new contrib
cat and fans in China call him the
greater Wall New York Times bestselling
author comedian and for mmer
w Kennedy uh Trump's idea is a good one
but that won't matter because it comes
from Trump have you never seen Ghost
Adventures no every time these ghost
hunting shows go to the most haunted
place in the world it's always former
asylums this is a horrible idea because
all you're doing is creating generations
of ghosts that are eternally damned and
that's because of involuntary commitment
involuntary commitment is one of the
most Grievous sins this cont and our
culture has ever committed against you
can't that again you you absolutely can
but I would rather see treating people
who are deeply mentally ill with things
like psychedelics I think there are
entire tools at our disposal that the
federal government has kept us from
really investigating that would truly
heal people and I think that is much
more revolutionary than repeating what
we've done in the past which hasn't
worked and I miss hobos right that the
haming way description of the homeless
where was adventuring with a stick and a
handkerchief and a can of beans we need
to bring that back that's called a
bindle called a bindle by the way okay
I'm with you on psychedelics but I don't
think you can mix and match a severely
mental ill person with say sbin you
can't it's not going to that's not
that's actually a worse idea because you
just assume it could solve every type of
mental illness I'd like to try i' I'd
like to have a program will we try that
all right all right Adam this is the
problem if if you're against forcing
people into treatment you will never
have treatment for a lot of people yeah
well I'm now classifying myself as
deeply mentally ill uh if they're going
to start doing that um no it's but it's
a problem I mean in Los Angeles there's
tents everywhere and I'm like I got to
cheer these people up so I went on and
got a bear costume you know um to give
them the full camping experience you
know
uh I was a cocaine bear cocaine
bear but no it's gotten so bad there was
a guy trying to Airbnb his tent um by
the way there were people getting close
to that like electricity refri you know
appliances it it's crazy I mean I you
know my my my cousin was in a mental
hospital and uh he would hear voices and
unfortunately none of them were don't
ask your cousin for money
uh but I mean something's got to be done
I don't know what yeah I mean everybody
cat stops at the you can't force people
to do anything but if somebody we put
people in prisons who are a danger to
others at some point we have to like
acknowledge that we have to move Beyond
just this like let's protect their
rights when they're harming other
people you you can't understand even a
little bit what the concern might be
about giving the government vague power
to lock people up against their will
just for saying that they're crazy I'm
sure there's people in the government
right now that would say that I'm crazy
even though I'm clear okay yeah my
life's falling apart my life's falling
apart I got nothing going for me oh jeez
uh you know but people will say you're
crazy like like men for example men love
to say women are crazy right they're
like she's so crazy she's so crazy I
don't talk to her anymore she's so crazy
but they leave out the sometimes years
of that they put the girl through to
make her react that
way so I no I don't trust the government
to get vague powers to lock people up in
institutions what do you think
Tyrus I think it should be a volunteer
program and I think you and I should
volunteer yes I think I think leave them
all outside and us who are really crazy
with like f and problem solving
abilities we go to in the facilities mhm
we just check ourselves in and I'm sorry
kids you can't come daddy sick but
everyone makes a point but you there has
to be because we're forced to live with
them we're forced to deal with them
we're forced to see the the the effects
when a woman's beaten when she's down
the street and they're like well it's
because of this it's well it's because
of this and we've the word mental health
is just like racist it doesn't mean
anything anymore because everyone has
something everyone is triggered everyone
is everyone acts like they they they
have PTSD from having to graduate you
know from a private school
so it's true like you know like oh
someone told me no once in the
supermarket and I've never gotten over
it I never forgave my mother for not
giving me Captain Crunch that day you
know but that's the that's the thing of
it so it it has to take Force because
they're in the encampments because this
is it you forced them all to live
together because they don't like living
together yeah a lot a lot of the issues
that they're having is someone's trying
to steal there's nothing more when
you're homeless there's nothing more
terrifying to you than someone taking
what little you have M so you will guard
that with by any means necessary
something as simple as us holding the
orange we won't think of a big deal but
to a homeless person they don't know
where that orange is coming from and
they're surrounded by people who will
take it from them so especially for
women in homeless encampments it's
literally every day their heads on a
swivel I remember one time we were doing
a big giveaway and we're giving clothes
away and this woman brought all these
beautiful dresses to give to homeless
women to make them feel better and every
one of them said there's not a chance in
hell I'm taking a dress MH I need pants
I need three or four pairs of pants M so
because the dress is no defense against
men so there needs to be something
forced I would have taken those dresses
yes you would have but you weren't
afraid of saying you know having your
clothes ripped off you in the middle of
the night if you did that you have to
pay a lot of money yes all right that
was a thoughtful conversation listen
something has to be done ugly to be
pretty but you both have good points
with yeah I don't want the government to
say one day hey you know tyus you're
crazy tyus got to go if you if you push
somebody in front of a Subway and you
say you got you still go to prison
pretty yeah I was going to say there
definitely already laws against that but
we have to wait for that that's the
thing we have to wait for that hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else